to keep the limb moving. So the limb moves by action of the muscles so you have to be contracting your muscles.
So your limb system does not have a heart.
Uses the muscle as it's important to squeeze the vessels and squeezes the fluid up through the capillaries, the limb vessels.
And then there's a check valve every three, four inches, the limb system until we can't go backwards.
So once you contract your muscles and sports it up through the system through the limb vessel and then we can't go backwards.
So that's the time you contract your moving limb through the vessels.
How you help to move fluid out of the extra cellular spaces into the limb system is action of movement.
So just like the person's comment back here that they're doing different exercises, trying to be very low impact type exercises.
That's the thing to do. You can do very light weights, get some pi pound of weights or two pound weights and do something like that.
That would fence. That's the right thing to do.
So Ellen who asked the question about the automobile course page on the website.
So that's where you clicked on it.
That's for the last.